good we're coming no that's not him how
the hell is this get here
what I want to break this I'm I'm good
we're getting thanks I'm what the hell
bucks get off me Oh Oh something's up in
this room
hey hey close them in close them in what
what's happening that doesn't change
anything you're gonna die anyway
what [ __ ] whatever you were okay I
got a great plan
actually I don't what's the [ __ ] room I
mean I don't want to go there I can't
select any of them trying that no [ __ ]
what do i do I can't go no [ __ ] what Oh
what whoa we check them oh wait huh no I
saw something hey hey hey what was that
what was that what some pasta yeah
minx my hiding spot is so good
get it oh there you are I see you minx I
think uh okay
now what are you hiding
I knew he was behind the part that you
shot me next day that he made oh you
moved apart like this hiding spot is the
best am i moving the table [ __ ] I am
I'm buying the big table story
it's a smallest stable size house what I
don't need to run what are you talking
oh no don't do it no no it's probably me
no I'd make you think that show yourself
now I'm the cactus [ __ ] do they really
get away holy [ __ ] - oh really at it
what Oh is he okay minx I have the best
one seriously Angie the best so I be
that as well
yeah and then come over here
oh I see yeah it's not good at all told
you what that we're downstairs okay no
more dancing yeah there's a hot dogs
what happened Martin run Frank yeah hey
soda machine smoothie machine well I
guess it's vending machines minks are
your life yeah how did you make it did
you just push it on behind you
I did why what thing are you there's a
lot of stuff on the projector how did
you see em move hey hey think you
somebody just left okay all right I want
to be one of these these are amazing
what are you talking about what you
changed into something how can you be
that Ming now let's get stuck when I
didn't get that line minx just had to do
her dames I was I was born to act Pete's
hey there's a hot dog hiding inside this
I'm gonna carry you around the entire
match mr. hot dog I'm watching the
projector it looks like it spoke the hot
dog is poking me when I ride there's
another hot dog there's hot dogs
anywhere yeah we call this we call this
phone a quorum in Sweden follicle how do
you go up there would you like my father
card I offer you my father card what
nice homies down here by the projector
against the wall dog dog yes looking me
myself well I'm just gonna keep looking
at that and oh there's so much fun you
[ __ ] up mr. chair oh nice that looks
really good like that looks legit I'm
gonna be one just because of my phasing
the sausage on a sausage like holding
that sausage in your head what in the
kitchen in the kitchen okay I'm with you
Oh pan frying pan oh no I killed myself
gravity damn you thanks Wayne grab your
sausage minks wait let me grab my
sausage
what I got a box full of sausages I
don't know my sausages are going
everywhere i trapped the sausage I
chopped it bite me a battle to the death
I want to Titanic music the sausage you
say that thinks will never be the same
you guys just want to play with your
sausage s instead of probably other sake
yeah crash the corner what are you
talking about what are you talking about
I saw it I saw it it's not in the
restaurant is not down there anymore
oh shut I'm trying to be a hot dog he's
a hot dog
if you don't kill me I'll give you one
of them oh let me okay eat it
put it all the way down your throat oh
that's a lot of blood probably robber
I'm just gonna turn around and
- stab in the back